The distance from the base of the building to the foot of the ladder, or the
bottom of the ladder, is 18ft. Great solving for getting this one right. This
one was tough. To start, we should begin with a diagram. We'll have a building
and then we'll have a 30ft ladder stretching from the ground up to reach the
top, or near the top of the building. We need to place the foot of the ladder,
this part, so that it's distance away from the building, is 6ft less than the
distance up the building. So if we let this distance be x, we know this
distance must be x minus 6. Now, this might look confusing. We see a distance
that's longer here, than it is here. Well, my drawings not to scale. Just
because you draw a diagram, it doesn't mean it needs to be perfect. We're just
doing a sketch of the situation so we can solve our problem. So, now that we
have our expressions for this side and this side and, we have a length of the
hypotenuse. We're ready to use the Pythagorean theorem. So, we'll square the
legs, and then we'll square the hypotenuse. This gives us x squared plus x
squared minus 12x plus 36 equals 900. Combining the like terms here we will get
2x squared minus 12x plus 36 equals 900, then we subtract 900 from both sides
to get this equation. Each of these terms is even, so we can divide our
equation by a factor of two. Now we want a factor of this quadratic. We find
factors of negative 432 that sum to negative 6. Those two factors are negative
24 and positive 18. Next, we set each factor equal to 0 and we solve for the
values of x. Positive 24 and negative 18. We know that this distance needs to
be positive, so this answer is out. This must mean that the distance from the
bottom of the building to the top of the ladder is 24ft. And the distance from
the base of the building to the base of the ladder is 18ft. Great solving if
you got all the way to the end. [NOISE]